I've never said this before and I can't
wait to say it it is so nice to meet you
Dolly Parton well it is nice to see you
too thanks for coming down from Canada
to see me this is my first time in
Nashville and I have to say when I
walked into my hotel room the first sign
I saw was what would Dolly do in the
hotel in the hotel room yeah your
movement your Legend but your movement
oh well I've been around a long time so
they do a lot of a lot of little things
in my name so some of them Fair some of
them not but I'm here so I've been at it
a long time it's such a pleasure getting
to talk to you now that you've been
inducted into the Rock and Roll Hall of
Fame has it sunk in that you're a rock
star no uh but it's soaking in a little
more because I I thought well timing is
everything and I my husband had always
told me I should do a rock album because
he is a huge I mean heavy metal Rock and
roller and so
um I I thought well maybe I will someday
but then when they wanted to induct me
into the Hall of Fame and I didn't think
I deserved it they wouldn't put me in
anyway I thought well I'm going to not
waste this time and so I am actually
doing a rock album of a lot of classic
rock songs and I'm going to actually
have a lot of the iconic singers and
musicians join me on some of the songs
that is so exciting you know the
ceremony you had pink there and you had
Brandi Carlile supporting you what was
it like getting their support well I
love them and I I just think they're all
great all those gals that were on the
show that not Pat Benatar and Linux and
and then of course uh you know Brandy
and pink and all the others that were
were there and it was just great to be
in that house with all those great
talented people and for them to accept
me and kind of make me feel welcome like
I was deserving of it whether I am or
not but I thought well I'm gonna I'm
gonna have to prove it right so I
thought well this is my time to do a
real rock and roll album a true rock and
roll not country at all wow but with
rock musicians Rock the singers and
everything you know I wrote with Kent
Wells who actually produced the album we
wrote A Few Originals together and then
I wrote some on my own so we're going to
have some classic singers and some
classic songs and some originals and I'm
calling it rockstar I thought why not of
course because I'm a rock star now you
are a rock star now
but I'm gonna I'm gonna take advantage
of of the timing this is so exciting is
there any artist that Carl is extremely
excited that you are working with well
uh he he loves all the songs and I
haven't told him yet who I was going to
to have on it I don't even know myself
who all is going to be on it but uh so
but he'll love it but he's I'm doing so
many of his favorite songs on the album
so I'll play it to him when it's all
done okay so because when you come out
next fall when you hit Legend status the
way you have uh there's certain myths
that pop up that seem to follow artists
around so I wanted to do a little
segment we call Dolly do or Dolly don't
and bust some of these myths you ready
okay is it true that you sleep with full
hair full makeup most nights when you're
on the road
well I don't I always wear my makeup and
I always if I don't have my own hair
fixed I have a wig on a lampshade or
something because you never know when
you're going to have to exit a building
and it's like when I lived in it when I
live in L.A I have a place out there and
there's always earthquakes and nothing
and you know you're always thrown out in
the streets and TV cameras and all right
yeah I think it doesn't matter when you
clean your face as long as you clean it
in a 24 hour period so I usually sleep
in my makeup and then I get up and clean
my face put it on again yeah so I try to
stay ever ready just in case I love this
about you okay and my husband likes it
too he does yeah he likes it rather than
going to bed with a shower cap and clear
seal on my face at least I look good
we've been married for 56 years this is
what works and I approve yeah
uh okay is it true that you love tattoos
and that you're covered in them under
your clothes I have a few tattoos
they're not uh for the sake of tattoos
although I enjoy seeing them because
they're past Tales but I have a tendency
Scar and my scars you know I'm so fair
and if I uh if I have something that I
just feel like I'd rather not look at
that scar then I'll I'll dress it up a
little bit so yeah it's true I have some
tattoos okay I love that is it true that
you have an entire room dedicated to
your wigs and hair pieces uh well I have
a closet that has shelves yeah and my
for clothes hair and makeup it's really
just a room for that type of stuff but
I'm always on I'm always changing
clothes every day you know so yeah I
have uh I have areas in in any house
that I'm in and I carry like if I carry
wig trunks on the road I have trunks
made that you know carry like three to
three to five wigs that you have if
you're doing shows it's just so handy
yeah and you know just trying to do my
own hair that much that high that I used
to do it years ago before the wigs and
it's just not all that healthy plus I'm
too busy to sit and do that well it's
one of the wildest rumors that you've
heard about yourself
oh heavens I've heard everything so I
don't know I don't think there's
anything I haven't well I think there
was one time um in inquire magazine that
my boobs were so heavy that it that they
had broken my back down and that I
couldn't get up that I was going to be
crippled for the rest of my life or some
something like that and I thought well
they are big and they are heavy but I
can still get around with them I'm doing
all right my back's okay my back's all
right if I had a back problem I don't
think it's because yeah that's such a
good one okay Christmas is right around
the corner uh it makes people so happy
what is one of your favorite holiday
traditions at home
well I love to do what every family
loves to do if you are a family you love
to get with family you loved each
favorite foods you need to say to which
sister who's cooking this this year we
all like to cook something that we loved
of mamas whether it's pot of chicken and
dumplings or whether we do Mama's
meatloaf or whether we do you know we
all know how to cook like Mama I cook
more like Mama than any of them
everybody says because I still cook with
grease and butter and things that makes
them taste good and my sisters they try
to live a little healthier but they can
still manage to make you know when I say
if you're cooking Mama's food you got to
cook it like Mama's and if you ain't
going to I'm cooking it right yeah we
all bring something to the table but we
love getting together singing and tell
stories and have the kids you know have
the presents and you know we my
husband's family and and my family and
then I live in Nashville my big part of
my family lives in East Tennessee so we
gotta travel around some to have
Christmas with everybody but that's half
the fun between Christmas and New Year's
we get it all in yeah I love that uh
would your husband Carl say that you
were on the naughty or nice list this
year uh I think damn I was a little of
both
like I said to somebody else on an
interview a while ago I'm gonna let
Santa decide on that one that's good is
Carl on the nice or naughty list both
yeah
that's why we've lasted so long we're
just naughty enough to be entertaining
and nice enough to make it last yeah I
love that and I'm sure people ask you
this all the time but is there a staple
answer for how you guys have lasted so
long 56 years well we love each other we
respect each other we both have a warped
sense of humor and I think humor
honestly I think that is one of the best
things when you're married like that
because even when you have a problem if
you have a great sense of humor rather
than going that way and you know if you
say something you can't take back that's
gonna so we we usually have some crazy
way of getting out of it but we've never
had you know serious arguments to say
bad things to each other we have to take
back so we've tried to do that with
humor but I like him and people say how
did it last so long I say I stay gone
there's a lot to be said about that each
other's face all the time right and we
don't he's not in the business so we
have different interests but yet we have
the things we love to do together